(waves crashing)
- [Johnny] In the last 200 years,
20 planes, 50 ships and hundreds of people
have just vanished in a small
area in the Atlantic Ocean.
This is a part of the ocean
called the "Bermuda Triangle,"
or the "Devil's Triangle."
It's an aquatic graveyard
where over the years
researchers have uncovered
hundreds of wrecks.
Scientific hypotheses have been crafted
to try to explain what is happening here.
The idea, the fear, has spread
sparking countless books and documentaries
attempting to prove that
there's something strange
happening in this triangle of ocean.
- [Speaker] There's some kind of a anomaly
going on down there that we can't explain.
Something that goes on down
far, far below the deepest
rays, the last rays of sunlight.
- [Johnny] In this video,
we're gonna explain what the mystery
of the Bermuda Triangle really is,
and why this perilous patch of ocean
has captured the curiosity and
fear of millions of people.
(ominous music)
Hey, I'm excited to get into this story
because it gets really juicy.
But first, I need to
thank today's sponsor.
Thank you, NordVPN for
supporting this channel.
A VPN allows you to surf
the internet safely.
With NordVPN, you click one button,
and it connects you to the
internet via a different country.
There's a lot of reasons that
one would want to do this.
For example, I've been
traveling a lot lately,
and I've been using NordVPN
to connect to the internet
via the United States
so I don't get kicked out
of like my email and stuff.
It also allows me to watch Netflix UK.
But these are just a few of
the mini benefits that NordVPN gives you.
For a very affordable price,
you can also be protected online.
NordVPN has a threat protection tool
that offers a wide variety of protections.
It blocks malicious trackers
and ads that you don't want,
all kind of just in the background.
You don't really need to think
about it, and it is there.
So if one of these many benefits
sounds interesting to you,
go to the link in my description
NordVPN.com/JohnnyHarris.
Clicking that link help
support this channel,
but it also gets you in
on this exclusive deal that
they're doing right now.
That's four months for free
when you sign up for the two year plan.
Oh, and you get 30 days to try it out
and if you decide you don't need it,
you can get all your money back.
Thank you to NordVPN for
supporting this channel.
Let's get back to the Bermuda Triangle.
It's generally regarded
as this area of water
in the North Atlantic,
drawn from Miami, to San Juan, to Bermuda.
The mystery here kind
of started back in 1492
when Christopher Columbus
who, incidentally,
is getting a lot of air
time on the channel lately,
for better or worse.
This is where the
biggest light bulb moment
of the century goes
off in this guy's head.
I know, I know.
The sources are in the
description, I'm sorry.
Can we move on, please?
Thank you.
Anyway, Columbus is out
there trying to reach Asia
and he passes through
this triangle of water,
and this is where things get weird.
Columbus kept a very detailed journal,
which I have a first edition
English translation of
that I'm not freaking out
about because I love old books.
Did I need to buy this for this story?
No.
Did I spend way too much
money on it as an excuse?
Yes.
But while I have it, let's look at it.
God, look at this freaking book, gorgeous.
Okay, anyway, on September 13th, 1492,
Columbus says that as he's
going along this route
something weird starts
happening with his compass.
On this day, "at the
commencement of the night,
the needles turned a
half point north-west,
and in the morning they turned
somewhat more north-west."
Whoa.
Creepy, Chris.
But it doesn't stop there.
He also reported the sea rising
and a strange light out in the distance.
He described it like a wax
candle moving up and down.
What is going on here?
The mystery continued
throughout the centuries.
In 1606, while traveling
through the triangle,
a large English ship
carrying 150 travelers
became wrecked at Bermuda
after encountering a huge hurricane.
Even though this wasn't mysterious,
because it was just weather,
it left an impression on how
people saw this body of water.
In fact, it is supposed
that this ship wreck
inspired Shakespeare's
play, "The Tempest,"
which often referred to
Bermuda, or Bermoothes,
as being vexed or cursed.
Okay, but listen to this one.
Next up is 1881.
This ship is sailing from
Liverpool to New York City.
When it passes through the triangle,
the people on board say that they
came across a ghost ship
with no one on board.
There are varying reports
on exactly what happened,
but the people on board generally reported
that some of the crew decided
to get on the ghost ship,
but then the ships were
separated by a massive storm.
When they were reunited with
the ghost ship the next day,
there was no trace of the crew.
This stuff is kind of spooky if true.
But wait, we're just
getting started because
when you get to the 20th Century,
that's when the Bermuda Triangle,
as a mysterious body of water,
started to gain a lot of attention.
In February, 1918, one of
the US Navy's largest ships,
the USS Cyclops, was carrying 300 men
from Salvador, Brazil
to Baltimore, Maryland.
The route goes right through
the Bermuda Triangle,
but the ship never arrived to Baltimore.
Despite being able to, The Cyclops
never sent out an SOS distress call.
No wreck was ever found.
As one article published
a few years after the disappearance said,
"Usually, a wooden bucket
or a cork life preserver
identified as belonging to a lost ship
is picked up after a wreck,
but not so with the Cyclops."
"She just disappeared as though
some gigantic monster of the sea
had grabbed her, men and all,
and sent her into the
depths of the ocean."
In an official statement,
the US Navy said that, quote,
"The disappearance of the ship has been
one of the most baffling mysteries
in the annals of the Navy."
That's an official quote.
Again,
kind of spooky.
Oh, and the Navy boats kept disappearing.
In 1941, the USS Proteus,
carrying 58 passengers
and a bunch of metal,
suddenly vanished within
the Bermuda Triangle.
And then one month later,
another Navy ship disappears.
61 people on board totally gone.
But it wasn't until 1945
when people started to
get really suspicious.
This is when a bunch of
World War II airplanes
were doing a three hour exercise
over Grand Bahama Island,
flying out and then pivoting
back to their airbase,
back in Fort Lauderdale, Florida.
But these planes never returned
and the disappearances
just kept happening.
A long haul flight with
25 people and six crew
disappeared in the triangle
without a trace in 1948.
And a year later, it happened again
to another plane of the exact same model.
All in all, there have been over
70 mysterious disappearances here
in this little patch of ocean,
where all those years
ago, Columbus noticed
something strange
happening with his compass.
With time, more and more
people started noticing.
One writer in the '50s said, quote,
"There have been other disappearances
in this backyard sea of ours;
and always the record,
when the account is finally closed,
has an ominous notation:
'No trace found.'"
And then in 1964, the
term "Bermuda Triangle"
was actually coined in an article.
Vincent Gadace asserted that, quote,
"Sea distances are relatively short."
Referring to the Bermuda Triangle.
"And yet this relatively limited area
is the scene of disappearances that total
far beyond the laws of chance."
People wanted answers.
10 years later, this book came out.
The author goes deep and
he makes the argument
that something is really
happening in the Bermuda Triangle.
It's not just bad weather.
This mysterious patch of water
is actually a gateway to
something much bigger.
And then he is not afraid to explore
some alternative theories
about ancient civilizations
and energy that was left
over from those civilizations
affecting this area.
It's magnets, it's
crystals, it's worm holes,
it's the ripping of space time.
These forces connect us
to the physical potential of our universe.
All shown to us because of the
mysterious disappearances
of the Bermuda Triangle.
No, no, no!
Come on, guys.
I hope no one was actually
following me down that
rabbit hole because,
you can't read a book like this,
talk about a bunch of mysterious things,
and call that evidence.
That is not what this is.
I was really into this for a moment.
Actually, when I was going
through all of the disappearances
until it started to become
about freaking crystals
and alien life coming to save
humans from nuclear fission.
We can't do this.
We can't present a handful of data points,
even if they're factually accurate,
separated by hundreds of
years and call that proof
that this patch of ocean is cursed.
What blows my mind is that this book,
the one that really put the
Bermuda Triangle on the map,
sold over 14 million copies worldwide.
It was translated into 22 languages,
despite being riddled with
completely invalidating errors.
I mean, what?
Come on.
I'm actually not surprised.
I mean, look at us.
Look at what we're doing here.
We're sitting here eating this
stuff up like it's ice cream.
People love this stuff.
Mysterious stories and finding connections
in observations that we
can see and understand.
I know that at least for me,
no matter how data minded
and objective I am,
I kind of get intoxicated
by a good mysterious story.
Our brains are like built for this stuff.
Especially when the storyteller
throws in little embellishments like-
Despite being able to,
The Cyclops never sent out
an SOS distress call.
This tendency is really concerning to me.
And honestly, more and more as I realize
how powerful of a tool storytelling is.
Especially visual storytelling,
where I can layer in the
music and the visuals
to make your brain think that it is real.
Okay, wait a minute, you're asking,
"Is this a video about
the Bermuda Triangle?"
"Or is this Johnny Harris's
current soul searching
about factual accuracy and
storytelling on the internet?"
It's both.
But let's keep going on
this Bermuda Triangle story
because there actually
is a very satisfying
evidence based answer
to what is really going on
with all these disappearances.
Here we go.
(tense music)
There have been some serious
scientific hypotheses
developed on what's going on here.
They range from things like,
the Bermuda Triangle having a
disturbance in geomagnetism,
which throws off compasses
and other navigational tools.
Remember, Columbus, creepy Chris?
Or methane blowouts,
which is a real thing.
We have these huge
deposits of like methane
under the ocean floor,
and if these blow up,
you get this massive explosion,
and then a huge crater
that just sucks down
anything that is floating on top of it.
That could easily explain it, right?
Okay, but then there's
the plane disappearances.
Here's another more simple
explanation, hurricanes.
The Bermuda Triangle is in the Caribbean,
which does seem to have an abnormal number
of high intensity storms.
That kind of makes sense.
And one popular theory
is that these storms
can cause what are called rogue waves,
which are massive waves that
reach a hundred feet or more.
Maybe it's those that lead
to the disappearances.
See, this is making more sense.
You've got methane gas, geomagnetism,
tons of storms in the Caribbean.
It makes sense that
this is a perilous place
for planes and boats.
These are scientific explanations
that validate the Bermuda Triangle.
We don't need Atlantis,
and crystals, and aliens.
We have geomagnetism and weather systems.
Rational explanations
for the Bermuda Triangle.
No, no, no, no!
Shine the light, folks
Do not fall for this, again.
No, another trap.
Me saying sciency things like
"geomagnetism" and "methane blowouts"
can sound like I'm presenting
strong evidence to you,
but I'm not.
I'm saying words.
I'm speculating.
Okay, so will we ever get
to the bottom of this?
Well, yes we can.
But not by listening
to me tell you stories
about ghost ships and
mysterious Navy disappearances,
or even 100 foot waves.
Instead, we need to
approach this differently.
Humans have developed an
amazing tool for seeing reality.
Instead of relying on
our own observations,
which usually need to
be couched as stories,
and that are limited by
how much we can hold in our brain at once.
Instead of this, we can
collect hundreds, thousands,
or hundreds of thousands of
observations about the world,
and they don't have to fit
in our brains all at once
because we can record them over time,
and then process and aggregate
them with math or maps.
And if you did that, you would see that,
of the tens of thousands of recorded
accidents or casualties at sea
recorded over the course of 20 years,
there wasn't anything
out of the ordinary here.
It doesn't even make the top 10
most dangerous ocean regions in the world,
at least according to another
analysis, another data set.
We wanted to make sure on this,
so we reached out to Lloyd's List,
which is a shipping publication
who graciously spent
months aggregating data,
tons of data about marine
casualties out to sea.
We found that 1.8% of all
vessels everywhere in the world
have some casualty, including
mysterious disappearances.
1.8%.
And that of the 8,634
boats that passed through
the Bermuda Triangle,
there were only two casualties.
0.02% of the boats that passed
through here had an accident.
90 times lower than the global average.
That was for 2021.
So yeah, that's the evidence
we should actually be
looking at and talking about.
It's not as tantalizing as
the stories told in this book
that sold 20 million copies.
But it's true.
It's what actually happened.
And the beautiful thing is,
you can then go and look at my sources,
look at the data sets that I used,
and you can interrogate them.
And you can come back and
tell me that my data is weak
because of the way it was
collected and what was left out.
That's called "discourse."
And it is the foundation
of how we know what we
know about the world.
All of us need to be vigilant of this,
perhaps me more than
anyone, I'm a storyteller.
But I also want to be a communicator
of true information about the
world, to communicate to you.
And yeah, we'll definitely disagree
on what that information means,
and how important certain things are.
Interpretation, opinion, et cetera.
But I'm here to make a further commitment
to going the extra mile
to gather the best truth I can
to make sure that it's actually real.
So, thank you for being here.
For being a part of my
discourse, my learning,
and to check me on this when I get loose.
And to make sure that together
we don't let the power of story
get in the way of the power of truth.
(low tempo music)
Hey, thanks for watching.
Something I didn't show in the video
was this model plane that
Nick, our studio manager, made.
- [Nick] It's a TBM Avenger,
one of the Flight 19 planes.
- Nuances, man.
I really appreciate you being here.
It's wild to see this channel grow,
and even wilder to see
the team behind it expand.
Like there's a lot of
people behind the scenes.
If you want to know more about
how we make these videos,
there is an entire
universe behind the scenes
that makes this all possible.
And we make a behind the
scenes vlog every month
that we publish for you to watch,
if you are a member of The Newsroom,
which is, effectively, access to scripts,
and interviews with experts that I do
that I just give you the full version of.
Custom tracks of music
from our composer, Tom.
And this this BTS vlog.
So The Newsroom is what
I'm calling our Patreon.
It's an extra video you get every month.
You also get to have an
influence on what stories we do
by voting on polls
that we are gonna be
doing in The Newsroom.
Also, voting on titles and thumbnails.
If anything, your support will allow us
to keep doing what we're doing and more.
To focus on working harder
for rigor, and truth,
and reporting, and journalism.
If you're unable to support financially,
please just keep watching the videos
and commenting and sharing.
At the end of the day,
having the audience here to show up
and be a part of this discussion
is the best support we have.
So if The Newsroom sounds
interesting to you,
check out the links below.
Thank you for watching.
Subscribe if you haven't already,
and I will see you in the next video.
"Several investigators of
the Bermuda Triangle mystery
have suggested that alien intelligences
may be interested or even concerned
in the possibility that our development of
nuclear fission for
warfare may be threatening
the existence of
civilization on our planet.
As it may have previously destroyed
other civilizations on
this and other planets."
"The time span of rational
man on this planet
of the intelligence
potential and comparable
to that of today may extend
back 40 to 50,000 years."
Oh, this is good shit, dude.